خطوات ثابته وصف واحد مئات الفتيات
السعوديات يتقلدن رتبا عسكريه في وزاره
الدفاع السعوديه بعد اتمام التدريب برا
وبحرا وجوا
[موسيقى]
الان انا ضابطه صف في القوات البحريه
واطمح مستقبلا ان شاء الله اني اكون في
احدى السفن التابعه للجلات الملك للقوات
البحريه طبعا حنا انا وزميلاتي في القوات
البحريه يعني كلنا ذو قدره وذو معرفه
ونستطيع ان شاء الله نوصل لهذا المكان
اللي احنا نطمح له باذن الله ابتداء برفع
العلم باستخدام السلاح وتطبيق النظريات
العسكريه وليس انتهاء باداء القسم استطاعت
المجندات السعوديات مقاومات الكثير من
العقبات في هذا المركز التدريبي تمهيدا
لمستقبلهن العسكري ان شاء الله نكون قدها
ونطلع
بنات او عسكريات مثل اعلى لخدمه الوطن على
صوره كامله باذن الله شعور جدا جميل فخور
جدا اني انا اكون في هذا المكان امارس
مهنتي
وفي نفس الوقت قعد امارس حلم فعلا كنت
احلم فيه اني انا اكون بهذا المكان طبعا
المجتمع ينظر للمراه دخول السلك العسكري
بالفخر والاعتزاز بفضل سمو ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان حفظ الله ورعايته
الوظائف العسكريه التي وفرتها السعوديه
للفتيات ساعدت في شغل متطلبات يحتاجها
القطاعان العسكري والامني مثل عمليات
المراقبه والحمايه داخل المقرات العسكريه
وخارجها
هانس فيان العربيه الرياض